يدخل اللاعبون الى كاس العالم باملي تمثيل
مشرف في بلادهم يخوضون غمار المباريات بكل
قوه الى ان تخونهم اجسادهم واصاباتهم تاتي
الاصابه مثل الكابوس لجميع اللاعبين في
كره القدم تضربهم في وقت ذروه المباريات
بينما يكون الحلم في اوجه لاكمال البطوله
العالميه وتحقيقها الاماكن تتنوع اصابات
اللاعبين بين ردود والتواءات مفاصل
والكسور والاجهاد العضلي والتمزق
والغضاريف والرباط الصليبي بينما قد تكون
الاصابه اكثر خطوره حين يتعلق الامر
بارتجاج المخ الجديد او الصدمات التي قد
تؤدي احيانا لفقدان الذاكره
وكسر في الجمجمه
[موسيقى]
ما سبب زياده وارتفاع عدد الاصابات في
مونديال كاس العالم كاس العالم
يقام في هذا التوقيت ماذا حدث الانديه
الاوروبيه الكبيره
انحاء العالم كانت بالفعل بدات هذه
الانديه لا تريد ان تخسر موسمها فتم وفي
نفس الوقت تم الاتفاق على اقامه كاس
العالم في هذا التوقيت فتم ضغط المباريات
بعد
الامر الشائع او الامر الطبيعي مرتين في
الاسبوع اصبح ثلاث مباريات في الاسبوع لكل
نادي وبالتالي الضغط له تاثير كبير جدا
على مساله الاصابات مساله اخرى ان التجمع
لكاس العالم هذه المره تم قبل اسبوع واحد
فقط من انطلاق البطوله الشائع قبل
البطولات الكبرى امم اوروبا كاس عالم
تحديدا كاس عالم ان يكون التجمع قبلها
بشهر فبالتالي لما بيجيء للمدرب لاعب مصاب
بيكون عنده يكون عنده وقت كافي انه يعالج
الاصابه هذه المره شعورنا بكابوس الاصابات
بسبب بسبب كل هذه المتغيرات
[موسيقى]